this quite obviously is a loft and it's
at the sharp end of all the talk we've
heard this week about energy saving it's
where heat vanishes through the roof
it's where your bills can also go and
the advisors to the government on
climate change well frankly they hit the
roof saying that the lack of policy over
this was a shocking Gap
also with me in the loft is Mark Cox is
busy laying some insulation and Mark
there seems to be installation already
here so why more it's not in a great
condition so we're currently topping up
the insulation to 400 millimeters
hopefully this will keep the heat in the
house the Bill's down and provide a
better environment
well can you give me a bit of a guided
tour of some of the other things you're
doing in here we've installed triple
glazing Windows within the property so
it helps keep the heat in
we've put external wall insulation I
can't see that so so the insulation is
behind this rendered finish you should
save 200 pounds a year on your energy
bills 200 pounds a year yeah just from
this rear external wall up to 200 pounds
a year for the average UK homeowner a
deep retrofit like this could cost
upwards of 20 000 pounds the good news
is your bills will drop rapidly but in
order to retrofit all the UK's aging
houses we're going to need a huge
skilled Workforce that simply doesn't
exist at the moment I was doing joinery
Plastering I Plumbing a bit a little bit
of everything and they asked for me
actually because I'm quite in the Eco
stuff
we're basically making the families pay
less once they move in if this actually
works and they get everything done by
the time scale is like 2035 would be a
massive help in order to meet the
government's Net Zero targets the number
of qualified retrofit Builders needs to
at least double over the next five years
alone
looks like the boss is here
there's an understanding that we have to
decarbonize every single building my
question is who is going to do that
we have a complete absence of skills
that's been building up over 25 years
within the construction industry
aliens company is training workers on
the job they're paid the living wage as
they train and they're all local if you
decided
okay I'm really going to invest
in this work in my home the thing you'd
want next
is a person you can trust to deliver it
those are the people we don't now have
enough of training on-site has stopped
full apprentices has stopped for at
least the last 20 years
a job placement is not fully trained a
short-term College course is not fully
trained the training needs to happen in
a house
so I've worked in housing since I was 19
my first ever job and I've been here
ever since and I think the reason being
you actually make a difference to
people's lives John is leading Stockport
homes retrofit Revolution they want to
upgrade all 12 000 of their homes if you
look at the housing stock across this
country in 20 30 40 years time the
housing stock that's here now will be
there then if we don't tackle it now
we'll never get to the targets which we
need to achieve for me it is sexy
because it's really vital that we do it
now it's a challenge or it's a challenge
that is a housing sector we're certainly
up far
foreign